while we're talking about sports i want
to bring something up
male innovation and ingenuity
yes
i don't know if this is popping up on
your guys youtube searches but god bless
the algorithm of god bless youtube
because they know what i like
even if i don't know that i like it okay
youtube
has realized that i enjoy
beautiful women's bodies
in not that much clothing okay okay
youtube figured that out very i don't
know how they got there completely
figured out but
there is some guilt to just googling
women's bodies yeah objectifying them
yeah
i'm not saying it's wrong but it might
be a little bit pervy right
it's just a random day you're watching a
video on youtube just some girl in a
bikini or something like that running
around that might be a little bit pervy
i got a wife what am i doing
youtube has realized
that
the pole vault
and the long jump
these chicks are built phenomenally
and they're forced by the olympic
committee to wear the tiniest garments
oh it's insane that that's put the
outfit absolutely insane their ass
cheeks are hanging out and they jump
into the sand and it just hikes those
underwear further up their ass so they
gotta pick it out every single time why
are they even jumping look at that i
can't even look
you can't even look if i look that i'm
checked out for the next five i mean
look at it it's crazy
goddamn it's [ __ ] and look at that
and then
you fought them
here so here's the thing oh that's
beautiful look at the precision we get
to watch this guilt-free because we're
not objectifying women actually we're
supporting we're progressive we're
supporting female athletics
we're supporting the last sports where
there's not um
trans women taking over
right
for real
imagine that just dick hanging out under
the bikini
there is something so funny that this
has happened you know
a million men oh dude it's all of us and
no one's talking about it nobody's
talking about it we are buddy that
didn't hit my algorithm those videos
don't know i have not hit him
look you go to italy track and field and
the thumbnail they know exactly what
they're doing look at these thumbnails
they know exactly what they're doing
i mean look at this
that
women's
crazy the italian pole vault pole vault
is nuts look at that thing though
it's also like italian woman's indoors
and it's like what random confederation
is this but the bodies are absolutely
ridiculous and she's holding a big old
pole and [ __ ] i mean it's just so sexual
yes this is brazilian indoor allows for
winter track and field
i don't even know if they're good that's
the crazy part but wow that's great oh
[ __ ] was that a joke or they really have
to wear this stuff no this is what they
have to wear i don't know what halftone
means i don't see them ever wearing
pants no there was another one that had
like at least boy shorts where it
covered a little bit more you don't see
bottom cheek that right there white
girls with fat dumpers super
for a white girl al sun white girls with
fat ass is it's a thing now son
i don't know plastic surgery doesn't
change the game it's just insane i mean
all the comments these are natural [ __ ]
and you can watch these and you can
watch these you can feel totally good
about yourself i heard there's a special
view it's more from spain
yeah christian
yeah oh you're here
bro this guy's all kept
in the comments
i think she's from italy but her name is
like christiane uh something like that
she's from spain 100 yeah i mean they
don't know what i'm talking about if you
think about the youtube channel if
they're not getting demonetized they're
making so much money doing
so little effort just like super cutting
ass and then making the thumbnail
i mean 100.
100 i mean
wow i mean like even though she's crazy
she's really
fernandez
i mean [ __ ] dude let them wear
[ __ ] pants
but she's actually like really nice
though i mean all the comments are crazy
she's a well-rounded athlete i'd stand
behind her
truly still with a large firm pole
athlete of the decade i love women's
sports
wow so glad we could all come together
for such an outstanding performance this
is hilarious
it's just the whole sub community now
that's going to get a high result from
the judges she also executed the pole
vault very well
yeah i saw one for different videos said
she's going to have an amazing future
behind her behind
so is this the future
i hope so is this the future isn't it
way better he bricked up some super
bricks i need to cover this
yeah yeah that was a fire part of
euphoria when the trans girl flips her
[ __ ]
did you guys not pick up on that i think
that wasn't in my version of watching
the show oh no it wasn't what version
did you watch
you see the [ __ ] the whole time like you
didn't see cox and euphoria you didn't
watch you for you know
but i didn't see you
you're [ __ ] somebody tweeted me that
yeah they said nah you said that yeah
bubble with that and then the
disappointment i saw is so funny
the fact that you were upset that they
were fake dicks
you're [ __ ] kidding me you betrayed
me it's more propaganda dude
it's real anymore dude you really think
that those are my dicks do you really
think that i don't know i hope so i
don't know i was inspired by those dicks
and those things aren't true
i mean some dicks i thought were fake it
was was mick steamy or mcdreamy was
that was really nick dreamy uh eric
that
no that's mcsteamy steamy yeah oh yeah
no his was fake
yeah
he didn't pull down his pants he just
took it out the hole
uh he unzipped it and took it out the
hole take the whole [ __ ] out fam if you
got it like that because i use a hater
you got it like that we would have seen
the dick with jewels if you had it like
that bro yeah we would have seen a dick
hang out for hours with a soft dick not
picking out yeah bro all the dicks are
prosthetics
lies
so why is he the only one that's faking
it
like that he ain't got it like that he
ain't got it like that bro come on mixed
stevie for a reason
i did google after game of thrones and
make sure hodor's dick was fake
because that [ __ ] made me feel weird bro
you know annoying that [ __ ] i didn't
even know horridor's dick was i don't
remember it at all
let me see how her door's dick wasn't
real no let me see horidor's dick thank
god bro i mean it makes sense with it
for his size for his size yeah but then
i'm watching to shoot my girl she goes
you think that's prosthetic and i was
like what the [ __ ] does that mean wait
which one is horridor's dick that one
yeah
that's my point that's why i googled it
i was like no that's fake it's big as
big as me
steamy's dick was bigger than that
bro
it was
yeah that's why i like jewels bro
i got everything i need oh how's the
feet i i don't know i got to look into
that but if she's 5 11 they're going to
be quite big and i'm not really that
into a bigfoot we don't know yeah jim
norton likes a big foot really yeah he's
telling me that i'm doing jim's saying
tomorrow
i'm about to leave
we got to talk about this there's a
moment where they're hooking up on the
bed and then i think zendaya goes or
leaves or does something and then she
has to like cool down like julia's like
hot and heavy [ __ ] to cool down and she
does the flip and tuck
i've never i don't see that what i've
never done that oh yeah yeah yeah uh was
it when she's hooked up hard dick up
yeah otherwise it's gonna hurt
what
yeah so say what you're saying right now
i've never tucked it in my waistband
it's gonna be more funny if he keeps
going let him keep going yeah i'm good
now on the mic i'm ready i'm on with him
yeah i've never tucked in your weight no
you guys y'all digging don't get hurt
the way you guys describe your dicks it
points up
mine's done it's just straight so if i
get it hard it's more comfortable if i
go through the leg
yeah i gotta go down a leg i gotta go
down a little bit dick let's go that's
that big it's small no it's not yeah
yeah it is
it is i'm telling you it's so heavy that
they don't go up it's not a heavy thing
if you're laying on your back
when you land your back what happens to
it yeah straight up yeah i'm talking
about standing up it doesn't curve up so
you would rather your dick so let's say
your dick goes like this right you would
rather push it down that way to fit in
your pants than just calmly fold it up
this way more on that commonly folded up
sounds
[Applause]
no way
joke no you have a reverse you have a
reverse column what do we do to help
them you guys have reverse columns
hey it's okay dude if you've got
something wrong with your dick it's all
good
maybe
it's just maybe you've never gotten more
than 70 of your dick shut up sorry you
duck just sweat fanning the whole time
up here that's crazy no it's crazy that
you would just have it forced down and
bent right
like when you're sitting down and you
get a hard on it's way more comfortable
it doesn't reach the waistband oh you
guys can't get it up to the waistband
what up people you just watched a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you